- [Instructor] Let's say we're told
that zero is equal to x
squared plus six x plus three,
what is an x or what our x is
that would satisfy this equation?
Pause this video and try to figure it out.
All right, now let's
work through it together.
So the first thing that I would try to do
is see if I could factor
this right hand expression,
I have some expression,
it's equal to zero.
So if I could factor it,
that might help solve.
So let's see, can I think of two numbers
that when I add them, I get six,
and when I take their
product, I get positive three?
Well, if I'm thinking
just in terms of integers,
three is a prime number,
it only has two factors one and three.
And let's see one plus
three is not equal to six,
so it doesn't look like factoring
is going to help me much.
So the next thing I'll turn
to is completing the square.
In fact, completing the square
if there are x values that
would satisfy this equation,
completing the square
will help us solve it.
And the way I do it, I'll
say zero is equal to,
let me rewrite the first
part, x squared plus six x,
and then I'm gonna write
the plus three out here.
And my goal is to add something
to the right-hand
expression, right over here,
and then I'm gonna
subtract that same thing,
so I'm not really changing the
value of the right-hand side.
And I wanna add something here
that I'm later going to subtract,
so that what I have in
parentheses is a perfect square.
Well, the way to make it a perfect square,
and we've talked about
this in other videos
when we introduced ourselves
to completing the square,
is we'll look at this first degree
coefficient right over
here, this positive six,
and say, okay, half of
that is positive three,
and if we were to square
that, we would get nine.
So let's add a nine there.
And then we could also subtract a nine.
Notice, we haven't changed the value
of the right-hand side expression,
we're adding nine and
we're subtracting nine.
And actually, the parentheses
are just there to help it
make a little bit more
visually clear to us,
but you don't even need the parentheses,
you would essentially get the same result.
But then what happens if we
simplify this a little bit?
Well, what I just showed you,
let me do it in this green blue color,
this thing can be rewritten
as x plus three squared.
That's why we added nine there,
we said, all right, we're
gonna be dealing with a three
'cause three is half of six.
And if we squared three,
we get a nine there.
And then this second
part, right over here,
three minus nine, that's
equal to negative six.
So we could write it like this,
zero is equal to x plus
three squared minus six.
And now what we can do is
isolate this x plus three squared
by adding six to both
sides, so let's do that.
Let's add six there, let's add six there.
And what we get on the left-hand side,
we get six is equal to,
on the right-hand side,
we just get x plus three squared.
And now we can take the
square root of both sides,
and we could say that the plus
or minus square root of six
is equal to x plus three.
And if this doesn't make full sense,
just pause the video a little
bit and think about it.
If I'm saying that something
squared is equal to six,
that means that the something
is either going to be the
positive square root of six,
or the negative square root of six.
And so now we can, if
we wanna solve for x,
we can just subtract
three from both sides.
So let's subtract three from
both sides, and what do we get?
We get on the right-hand side,
we just are left with an x,
and that's going to be
equal to negative three
plus or minus the square root of six.
And we are done.
And obviously we could
rewrite this and say,
x could be equal to negative three
plus the square root of six,
or x could be equal to negative three
minus the square root of six.